hello everyone and welcome back to
chessable masters group
b uh we have a very exciting game
between maxime vacher lagrave and
fabiano corwana
uh two contenders of the 2020 candidates
tournament
uh and it's uh well it's just a very
exciting game as the title suggests so
let's
just uh dive straight into it maxime
with the white pieces opens with
d4 uh we have d5 by fabi and
c4 sorry about that uh and here uh fabi
goes for c6 he goes for the slav defense
probably to not disclose anything he has
maybe planned for the candidates
although i don't think they are
maybe they were trying to do so at first
but i don't think anyone is concealing
any preparation
since we don't really have any idea when
the candidates will resume
uh so uh c6 the slav defense knight f3
knight to f6 and now queen to c2
defending the pawn here also fighting
for e4 square
uh we have d cap presidency for queen
captures and the bishop of the f5 this
is the
most uh played line of the slav in 2020
so
very modern uh we have g3 and e6 now as
the
the light square bishop has been
developed you can now close the
structure now we have bishop to g2
and bishop to e7 both players prepare to
castle
and they do so castles castles uh and uh
here
uh the most often uh move here is knight
to c3 just continuing development
but maxim wants to mix it up already
with queen to b3 he puts pressure on b7
and much like you would have in uh
pretty much uh
well most slavs queen to b6 the queens
do stare at each other and the white
wants black to capture so he gets a
semi-open file for his rook and black
also wants white to the capture so black
would get a semi-open file for the rook
so knight beat to d2 uh maxime continues
development and
fabi does the same uh we have knight to
c4 now trying to get
fabi to trade on b3 uh but fabi just
moves it so queen to a6 still defending
b7
but also if the knight moves in some
lines maybe the e2 pawn can be
vulnerable
uh and here there is uh well there is a
game where knight seat the e5 was played
also rook to d1 is a known move in this
position
but bishop to g5 the move maxine plays
is a new move so
already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game
uh and uh of course fabi just continues
development knight b to d7
and the knight can come to b6 challenge
white's knight on c4 we have rook
f to e1 and now h6 asking do you want to
trade or do you want to go back so fabi
goes back
sorry mvl goes back we have bishop to f4
and now knight to b6 with a double
attack on the knight here now asking
uh do you want to trade on b6 or not uh
and fabi says no thank you so
no sorry maxine uh knight c to e5 uh
and here finally as uh white is
controlling a lot more space
we have queen to a4 by fabi now offering
a queen trade here
uh which is usually a good idea when
your control when your opponent controls
uh
much more space and here bishop back to
d2
maxim's idea is that if fabi is eager to
trade now for example captures captures
and let's say knight b to d5 then he can
be very annoying with this bishop to a5
move
you cannot play b6 because then the c6
spawn hangs and then you can also pick
up the bishop with
check so white would definitely come on
top of that uh a little combination
so after bishop d2 fabi first adds
another defender to the c6 pawn with
bishop to e4
now nicely defending the c6 pawn and
here maxime decides to trade with
captures captures and now
b3 uh we have knight back here and now
the b3 pawn will nicely uh
uh prevent fabi's knight from jumping to
these squares uh
and bishop to a5 now pinning the knight
nut allowing us to
to come to d5 so here uh fabian pins we
have rook to d5
and now as the bishop is no longer
needed here bishop back to c3 just
adding another defender here
finally c5 uh maxine uh fabi really
wants to get rid of this spawn
uh i don't know why if this game i'm
constantly uh mixing up their names
really really weird
uh and here just e3 adding another
defender to the d-pawn
and rook d to d8 now not rook 8 to d8
doubling up on the d file but rather now
fabi just wants to free up the d5 square
for his knight
which was the intention all all along so
here
rook e to d1 uh and now knight b
to d5 challenging the bishop here we
have bishop to a5
now trying to provoke more weaknesses so
you weaken the c6 square
however just rook d to ca this was
fabi's idea by going back bring up the
d5 square for the knight
and rook a to c1 now by mvl uh now you
can go b6 as the rook also covers the c6
square so bishop back all the way to e1
and now a5 expanding on the queen side
uh
mbl does the same with a4 and now uh
rook to c7 now fabi's preparing to
double up on the c file maybe push c4
and try to create some some chances
along the c file we have knight to c4 by
mvl
and now going for for the b6 spawn maybe
in the future will be possible
uh and just rook a to c8 doubling up
here we have
d captures on c5 uh sort of a sort of a
nice capture fest will now
take place uh we have bishop captures on
c5
grabbing that and now knight the d4
opening up
a discovery on the bishop here captures
captures and here
bishop captures on d4 we have rook
captures on d4
and now knight to d7 uh envious rook on
c1 is undefended so here maybe you can
just
attack it once again with knight to e5
put a lot of pressure on this knight
here
however mvl beats him to the punch with
e4
now this knight has to move knight uh 5
to f6 and now rook c
to d1 getting this rook out of arms away
and now nicely doubling up on the d file
and rook to b8 by fabi
here mvl could be having some plans of
maybe rook d6
f3 strengthening the e4 pawn and going
after the b6 pawn so fabi just defends
it
uh prematurely and also prepares b5 to
bust open the position here
so f3 and we'll strengthen the center
and now kink to h7
just uh a safer square for the king
maybe you can also bring it into the
game
after king g6 we have g4 by white now
taking away the h5 square from the
knight and also just preparing
h4 g5 and so on so here e5 by
fabi and now uh here a rook the d6
envio just continued with his plan but
bishop to g3 was
also very interesting because if
captures then just captures
and this point would be very weak on d4
and you would be having a lot of targets
here after bishop captures on c7 so it
wouldn't really
be all that great for black however mvl
continues with his original plan rook d6
and now knight to c5 here uh
just uh fabi just uh tries to give up uh
the e5 pawn for the b3 pawn and mvl
accepts this he goes for knight captures
on e5
we have knight captures on b3 and now uh
h4
now that the rook is nicely covering the
sixth rank you want to play g5
let's say captures captures kick away
the knight and then put a lot of
pressure on the black king
uh so here we have b5 uh fabian now of
course wants to play on the queen side
as mvl tries to attack on the king side
with b5
at least one pass pawn will be created
so uh
it does make sense to go for this uh but
nvl continues with his king side plans
so g5 uh we have knight to h5
uh with some knight to f4 check ideas in
the future
and knight to d7 now a very
very interesting move by mvl uh and here
he asks
white black what do you want to do your
rook is under attack if you move the
rook somewhere else i'm just going to
gobble up your pawn so you could play
rook
uh beat the b7 and then just wait for me
to do my thing but then you uh
leave the the back rank uh uh open to
some
checks here knight a fade the rook can
come to back to the back rank
so here instead fabi goes for a more
active plan
he gives up the pawn uh with rook uh
beat the c8
uh and maxime accepts it and now uh by
accepting it
both players now have created a pass
pawn and uh fabi immediately starts
pushing it
which does make sense as his knight
already controls the a1's
queening square but uh maxime's knight
also controls the b8 queening square so
maxim also starts pushing b6
uh we have rook to b7 and now uh bishop
to b4 maxim prevents uh fabi from
pushing the ball all the way to a3
we have knight to f4 check king the g3
and now knight back to e6 helping out uh
with with
the defense uh and here mvl goes for the
very strong king to g4 you could play a
lot of moves here like
captures you could play f4 f5 but mvl uh
wants to bring the king closer to the
action
and here black's position is very very
difficult to play
uh it's uh you can't really move the
rooks this rook has to stay here
otherwise b7 will will come at some
point you cannot push
a3 this knight doesn't really have any
good squares the c5
is covered twice and you don't really
want to trade even further
and uh it's really not not an easy
position for example you could try
something like rook c4
to try and disconnect the white rooks
let's say bishop a3 and now knight to d4
now you've disconnected the rooks
however after bishop to b2 it's again
very hard for black to find to even find
a move
so instead after this king to g4 move
fabi went for
rook to c2 he wants to play something
like captures captures and then rook to
g2 check to pick up the g5 pawn
with a very clean idea however uh
this completely loses the game uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find
the winning idea for mvl while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
you can remove the defender of the
knight and e6 and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
g6 check and here no move is good for
example if you capture
then uh you no longer defend the knight
just rook captures knight which is of
course completely winning for white
on the other hand you could go to h8 but
then just f g captures on f7 creates a
winning pass pawn so it only makes sense
to go to g8 but
then you get the g captures with czech
king captures and knights the e5 uh with
check and now after king moves to f6
now just uh rook to d5 and that there is
isn't really a lot black can do here the
king will be overrun by
white's pieces for example if you try
something like rook g2 checking h3 and
rook back to e2
then it's just knight to g for check and
there are no good moves here
you don't want to go here in front of
the bishop so you might go king to f7
but then rook d7 check and let's say
after this is all traded captures
captures king g6
now uh the b pawn is winning you don't
want to run into some uh
knight f4 check uh trickster for
to allow let's say black a perpetual
knight for check followed by knight h5
check and so on since the rook
covers this but a nice let's say h5
check just taking away the h5 square
from the black knight
will uh be uh easily winning for white
let's say knight
now after checking g3 and now there's
nothing to be done here
next move you're gonna queen and win the
game so instead after g6 maxi uh
fabi did the only thing he could he
played king captures on g6 but
now uh now it's actually a force to
check mate in four so
feel free to pause the video once again
and find try to find the exact sequence
that mates in four
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
on finding the exact sequence that wins
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's knight to f8 check not leaving the
king with any ideas
the these squares are taken so the king
uh only square for the king is f6 and
now comes uh
the move that uh makes it all uh
possible
e5 with check leaving black with two
options but none of them are good it's
either captures or king e7
if you decline this juicy pawn then
after king e7 it's
uh now you're in front of the bishop so
rookie six is checkmate
it's really wonderful as the knight
defends the rook it's actually a double
check from the rook and the bishop so
you have to flee it's the old saying
even the laziest king flees in the face
of a double check
and everything is nicely protected the
bishop defends the knight the knight
defends the rook and this recovers the
entire d
file so nothing to be done here so you
would have to capture on e5 which fabi
did
and now comes uh rook 6 6 the d5 this
comes with
check only one option for the black king
king of six and now uh
the finishing move rook to f5 checkmate
as the knight covers g6
pawn king and recover this and the
bishop covers e7 uh of course the king
has nowhere to go
so that's the game really really a
spectacular
game 50 moves but ending with a
checkmate on the board very
rarely happens between such such elite
players members of the candidates
tournament here
so i i do hope you enjoy that uh and
yeah
i would also like to thank joshua
squasher heartwood geckola
triquel islam uh brian seawell and juan
vincent alvarez for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
and also i would like to thank over 100
of you who joined the membership program
yesterday
i do not have enough room here on the
interface to name all of you but
the agarmator.com website is almost
fully operational and you will all be
credited
there under supporters and contributors
so thank you all for that as well
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it
and i will see you guys soon have an
excellent rest of your day